Airbnb is a big deal not the valuation
but the business Airbnb is fundamentally
changing the hotel industry Airbnb is
gross bookings last year were 240
million according to precone that's
approaching Marriott's 1 billion
Starwood's 2 billion Hyatt a 2 billion
in Hilton it's 4 billion that's a big
deal and Airbnb is growth is at the
expense of hotels the Boston University
study found that for every 1% increase
in air B&B business the rest of the
hotel industry Falls by 5 basis points
and think about it Airbnb is growth is
unconstrained by limits of real estate
or capital last year Airbnb CEO boasted
on Twitter Marian wants to add 30
thousand rooms this year we will add
that in the next two weeks at the end of
last year according to privCo Airbnb had
90 thousand rooms here's the comparison
Starwood 340 6,800 Marriott 373,000 253
and 670,000 630 rooms at Hilton but now
Airbnb boasts 550,000 listings that's up
over 500 percent on the end of last year
and according to Airbnb Airbnb guests
stayed on average five nights compared
to 2.8 nights at hotels and they spent
more Airbnb says users spend nine
hundred seventy eight dollars per trip
nearly half more than hotel guests and
Airbnb listings are unique 57% of them
are apartments or complete houses while
41% are just one room and 2% are shared
rooms and what percentage of Airbnb
hosts pay rental income taxes well that
number is between the host and god and
the IRS